hello everyone anyone one the under-16
World Youth Championship in Uruguay and
she did it with a result of ten and a
half out of 11 points and well this is
quite spectacular as well if you
consider his/her rating she wasn't even
in the top ten of the of the
participants in the tournament and well
the the top contender was Polina
Chuvalo uh from Russia rated somewhere
well um almost 2400 and this is the game
I want to show you ne Wang versus
Paulina Chihuahua and Annie was rated
somewhere below 2100 I think it's 2009 T
so there is a difference of about 300
rating points and well like I said she
wanted to with ten and a half out of 11
points and she won 218 rating points
during this tournament so that's that's
quite a jump
I think her new rating will be above
above 2,300 so let's see it Polly
Marshall álava of Russia has the white
pieces and any wank has the black pieces
we have d 4 + e 6 the Horovitz
defense - the Queen's pawn opening g3
Knight to f6 Bishop to g2 d5 Knight to
f3 Bishop to e7 castles castles and c4
and the game transposes into the Catalan
opening D captures on c4 and knights to
e5 and any plays Knight to c6 inviting
white to triple to triple her pawns
so Knight captures and c6 b captures on
c6 and knights to a3 and well this is
inviting black to give up his bishop
pair so Bishop captures on a three b
captures on a three and the black does
have these tripled pawns here but he
also have he also has I mean she she
also has a test C pawn here this will be
a very strong pawn bishop to a6 are
developing the bishop and adding
protection to the c4 pawn and Bishop
captures on c6 grabbing that one of the
pawns rook to b8 rook to e1 and Brooke
to b6 kicking the bishop away from c6
Bishop back to g2
and Queen to e7 we have Queen to c2 rook
F to be a doubling up on the B file and
E 4 we have Knight to d7 e5 and night to
f8 and this night to f8 it seems like
it's a way back but it's actually adding
needed protection to this h7 pawn and
also he's ready to jump into the game
with with Knight to g6 if needed so h4
Queen to d7 Bishop to e4 and here any
place a queen to b5 you can't capture
this pawn here with King caption before
because you lose the rook and b6 well
the exchange so after Bishop before
Queen to b5 now completely owning this B
file a4 and Queen to b4 attacking the
rook on e1 rook to e3 now H 6 H 5 and
the Queen back to e7 and Bishop to a3
now developing this dark squared bishop
would an attack on the Queen Queen to e8
and rook to d1 Queen to d7 is played
Rock 2 C 3 C 6 and here pulling a plays
Queen to e2 a much better plan would be
for example to push g4 and continue this
with rook to g3 and pushing of the Jeep
on but okay we have Queen to e2 now
Queen the c8 and a queen to f3 we have
nice - h7 and the Queen to III and that
jumps to g5 this is a gray square for
the knight you can really kick it away
from there if you don't want to push f4
Bishop to see - not allowing the knight
to capture it Queen to d7 and now Bishop
to d6 attacking that broken b8 and this
is well this is a pretty good square for
the bishop Rock the c8 and now f4 and
that goes back to h7 and the g4 is
played we have Queen to d8 preparing to
infiltrate white position with Queen to
h4 rock the detail now Queen to h4
attacking the pawn on g4 and rook to g2
and nice to f8
the here Polina plays Bishop to c5 we
have worked to b7 Queen to e4 now adding
this permanent threat of queen to h7 the
knight can't really move from f8 we have
Brooksie to b8 and well she allows the
Bishop captures on f8 because the King
will be able to wiggle out with King to
f/8 and 1337 so Roxy to g3
doubling up on the G file and we have
worked a bit too
the plan is to capture this pawn on a2
and put the other broken b2 and really
add some threats here so we have g5
Queen captures on h5 and here we have G
captures on h6 but actually in this
position it was better to capture this
bishop this night with the Bishop
captures on f8 but ok we have G captures
on h5 ninth to g6 is played and here
Polina plays rook to g5 and well this is
the critical position the critical
position in the game well here any plays
Queen to h3 but better was to capture
this pawn on h6 Queen captures on h6 and
after rook to h2 now attacking the
screen this knife to h4 move really goes
in blacks favor
why doesn't really have a way of taking
taking advantage of this but okay after
rook rook to g5 any plate Queen to h3
and this is where Polina blunders of the
game away there is a completely clear
path the victory here the idea of course
is rook captures a knight on g6 and
after F captures rook Queen captures
pawn on g6 and black can't really do
anything to stop Queen captures on g7
without losing a lot of material but
after this Queen to h3 move
polina played H captures on g7 what are
this this was due to time pressure or
something
I do not have this information but now
while this white pawn on g7 is
completely protecting the black king
from from the doubled rooks on the G
file rook captures on a to continue with
the plan because white doesn't really
have any decisive threats here rook
captures and g6 isn't really isn't
really doing anything here because now
there's a rook day one check King to
have two and now capturing and after the
Queen captures well c4 white doesn't
have any immediate strikes and well the
threat of rook to f1 check is it's
terrible I mean at the disposition it
will be checkmate but white would have
to give up material to prevent this for
example queen h7 checked Queen captures
Bishop capture screen captures and black
is up a piece this past C pawn is ready
to become a queen this is completely
winning for black so after rook captures
on 8 - Queen to e1 was played rook the
b2 rugby to be - and well here you could
still probably continue to play this
with white would a move like rook to h2
now attacking the Queen and after Queen
captures on h2 sacrificing the Queen for
two pieces King captures and rook
captures and c2 with check King to g3
and for example c3 black is better here
but she would still have to work for her
for her full point but after this rugby
to be to move
polina played Bishop to e4 and now white
is completely lost any played knife
captures on f4 adding an additional
attacker here to g2 Queen to f1 was
played and now c3 opening up a
discovered attack from this bishop on e6
to the Queen and f1 Bishop to h7 was
played Queen captures on h7 rook
captures and b2 and now the simple C
captures on b2 and in this position
Felina chaiwalla resigned the game as
well here her queen is still attacked
and
if the bishop is captured moves like be
one Queen are coming or if white doesn't
really do anything
rook to a one is coming there is no
defense with best defense it's checkmate
in four moves but in this position pull
you know resigned the game and well it's
a it's a one hell of a victory for young
any Wang so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it you can check out
some of her other games as well as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here I do hope you enjoyed this game and
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon